foreign
the wife of a man killed in a high-speed
car crash says there's no justice in the
deal the driver is taking in court today
that driver one time UNLV basketball
recruit Zeon Collins today Collins says
he will agree to a plea deal the
victim's wife is critical of R8 news now
investigator Kyle Payne joins us live in
studio with what exactly happened in
court Kyle Kirsten Zion Collins was
looking at several years in prison on
the two charges related to that crash
that happened back in December 2020.
those were DUI death and reckless
driving this was the scene in court
today court documents said Collins who
was 19 at the time was doing almost 90
in a 35 mile an hour Zone when he
crashed his car that wreck killed a 52
year old man Eric echeveria who worked
at a Clark County Middle School here's a
scene in a justice courts today as
Collins at the time tested just over the
legal limit for pot at the time of the
crash it took quite some time for the
state supreme court to throw out Colin's
challenge of those test results and
today it looks like his charges are
being boiled down to probation on the
felony reckless driving and 90 days for
misdemeanor vehicular manslaughter
Mr Collins do you understand those
negotiations
have you discussed these negotiations
with your attorney do you want to accept
those negotiations
there is sufficient evidence the
defendant joseon Collins has committed
to defense said offenses I hereby order
that he'd be bound over and held to
answer in the eighth Judicial District
Court Collins was a highly ranked High
School recruit from here at Bishop
Gorman who ended up signing at UNLV in
2020 saw us as they called him never got
to play for the rebels because of the
deadly crash he is a free man currently
being monitored by a GPS bracelet that
will change if a district court signs
off on the deal he agreed to in court
today that will happen next Thursday
it's a deal the victim's wife says isn't
even worth discussing she told me on the
phone quote it's a done deal there's
nothing I can do about it she said
there's nothing to talk about Brian all
right Kyle thank you for that now he
will Collins back in Criminal Court a
week from today the victim's wife filed
a wrongful death suit against Collins in
civil court in November of 2021 that
case is still ongoing Kirsten